رغم ان الفلبين اعتادت تعرض للكوارث
الطبيعيه لكن المعركه مع الطبيعه هذه
المره ربما هي الاكثر قسوه عندما واجهت
اعصار بوفا الذي قتل مالا يقل عن الف شخص
وشرد مئات الالاف في جنوب البلاد فما الذي
حدث في اواخر نوفمبر من العام 2012 ضربت
الفلبين موعد مع عاصفه بوفا الاستوائيه
التي صنفت بالفئه الخامسه والاقوى على
الاطلاق بين الاعاصير التي ضربت جزر
الفلبين الجنوبي
بدات الكارثه عندما اشتدت سرعه الرياح
لتتجاوز 175 ميلا في الساعه ثم تحولت الى
اعصار هائج حرك الاشجار والصخور والاتربه
قبل ان يصل الى اليابسه في الثالث من
ديسمبر
عبر الاعصار الى المناطق الجنوبيه والوسطى
من جزيره من دناو حيث يسكن اكثر من 6
ملايين ومئتي الف شخص في 30 مقاطعه حيث تم
اجلاء اكثر من 170,000 شخصا الى ملاجئ من
العواصف
فيما ادت الرياح والامطار والغزيره الى
انهيارات ارضيه ودمار بالمنازل كما تهدم
نحو 18 جسرا ما جعل بعض المناطق معزوله
تماما وباتت مساعده العالقين هناك بحاجه
الى وسائل نقل عن طريق البحر او الجو
لم يتمكن الكثيرون من تلقي المساعدات
بسرعه كما دمرت الاراضي الزراعيه ونفقه
العديد من قطعان الماشيه التي تعد مصدر
دخل لغالبيه السكان هناك كما تقطعت خطوط
الكهربائي والمياه في الكثير من المناطق
وبذلت المنظمات الاغاثيه جهود كبيره للبحث
عن المفقودين كما وفرت ملاجئ مؤقته
للناجين واصلحت المساكين لاكثر من 2000 و
2500 اسره كما انشات قيام المساعدات
الطبيه وقامت بعمل خزانات مياه متنقله
لقى اكثر من 1,000 شخص مصرعهم
ودمر ما يقرب من 200,000 منزل وتشرد مئات
الالاف حيث قدر عدد النازحين مع مطلعي
يناير من العام التالي بنحو 800 و50,000
مع حلول السابع من ديسمبر انتقلت العاصفه
الى بحر الصين الجنوبي وغرب مقاطعه جزيره
بالالوان حيث بدات في التبدل
حصلت الفلبين على مساعدات وتعاهدات دوليه
بنحو 11 مليون
و800,000 دولار من المانحين الاجانب
ومساهمه اضافيه قدرها مليون
و780,000 دولار من خلال الوكاله الكنديه
للتنميه الدوليه وهي المبالغ التي قدرت
لتجاوز الخسائر الماديه اما الخسائر
البشريه والمعنويه فتركت كاننا يسمع في
زوايا الجزر المنكوبه